the job of the function D which you
learned about in the last video is to
input two faces and tell you how similar
or how different they are a good way to
do this is to use a Siamese Network
let's take a look you're used to seeing
pictures of confidence like these where
you input an image let's say X 1 and
through a sequence of convolutional and
pulling and fully connected layers and
with a feature vector like that and
sometimes this is fed to a softmax unit
to make a classification but we're gonna
not going to use that in this video
instead we're going to focus on this
vector of let's say 128 numbers computed
by some fully connected layer that is
deeper in the network and I'm going to
give this this of 128 numbers a name I'm
going to call this f of X 1 and you
should think of f of X 1 as an encoding
of the input image X 1 so it's taken the
input image here this picture of kion
and is re representing it as a vector of
128 numbers the way you can build a
face-recognition system is then that if
you want to compare two pictures let's
say this first picture with this second
picture here what you can do is feed the
second picture to the same neural
network with the same parameters and get
a different vector of 128 numbers which
represents or which encodes the second
picture so I'm going to call this second
picture so I'm going to call this
encoding of this second picture f of X 2
and here I'm using X 1 and X 2 just to
denote two input images they don't
necessarily have to be the first and
second examples in your training sets it
can be any two pictures finally if you
believe that these encoding x' are a
good representation of these two images
what you can do is then to find the
image
of distance between X 1 and X 2 has the
norm of the difference between the
encoding of these two images so this
idea of running two identical
convolutional neural networks on two
different inputs and then comparing them
sometimes that's called a Siamese neural
network architecture and a lot of the
ideas I'm presenting here came from this
paper due to yawn of Tackman Minyoung
marker really Renato and Leo wolf in a
research system that they developed
called deep face and many of the ideas
I'm presenting here came from a paper
due to yawn of Todman Minyoung marker
really Renato and Leo wolf in the system
that they developed called deep face so
how do you train this siamese neural
network remember that these two neural
networks have the same parameters so
what you want to do is really train a
neural network so that the encoding that
it computes results in a function D that
tells you when two pictures are of the
same person so more formally the
parameters of the neural network define
an encoding f of X I so given any input
image X I the neural network oprah's
this engine 28 dimensional encoding f of
X I so more formally what you want to do
is learn parameters so that if two
pictures X I and XJ are of the same
person then you want that distance
between their encodings to be small and
in the previous slide I was using x1 and
x2 but is really any pair X I and XJ
from your training set and in contrast
if X I XJ are of different persons then
you want that distance between their
encodings to be large so as you vary the
parameters and all of these layers of
the neural net
where you end up with different and
coatings and what you can do is use back
propagation to vary all those parameters
in order to make sure these conditions
are satisfied so you've learned about
the siamese network architecture and
have a sense of what you want the neural
network to output for you in terms of
what would make a good encoding but how
do you actually define an objective
function to make your new network learn
to do what we just discussed here let's
see how you can do that to the next
video using the triplet loss function